19 c'est le nombre d'incendies qu'un
homme de 50 ans a reconnu avoir commis à
proximité de son domicile à la riche
Joué-lès-Tours et saint genou entre
février et juillet dernier
principalement des feux de voiture et de
cabanon de jardin mais aussi celui du
club house du stade Jules Ferry a
Joué-lès-Tours l'auteur présumé avait
été arrêté début juillet et placé en
détention provisoire il comparaissait
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal de Tours
Léa Turquie était sur place
la Cour s'est prononcée l'incendiaire de
la riche et Joué-lès-Tours et condamné à
trois ans d'emprisonnement et à trois
ans d'interdiction de séjour sur les
communes de la riche et saint genou
l'homme de 50 ans est jugé coupable des
séries d'incendies qui se sont déroulées
entre février et juillet 2023 sur les
communes de la riche sans genou et
jouaient les tours des voitures des
cabanons de jardin un camion benne le
club house du stade Jules Ferry incendié
la liste est longue à la barre l'homme
conteste aujourd'hui la majorité des
faits des faits qu'il avait reconnu au
moment de sa garde à vue il explique
avoir besoin d'un suivi psychiatrique et
annonce avoir des visions lui ordonnant
de brûler ses véhicules dans ma tête
j'étais pas tout seul il fallait que je
sois soigné une expertise psychiatrique
a été menée concluant sur une possible
altération du discernement du
quinquagénaire au moment des faits
l'homme a déjà été condamné à plusieurs
reprises pour des faits similaires
toujours dans la métropole tourangelle
il a été interpellé le 2 juillet dernier
prix en flagrant délit dans le quartier
des Minimes de la riche il dispose
maintenant de 10 jours pour faire appel